selon IMDB le deuxième meilleur film de
2022 est top Gun Maverick ce film est la
suite du premier volet de Top Gun apparu
en 1986 et clairement il s'agit là de
contenu de top qualité audiovisuelle
mais ces contenus devraient-ils vraiment
être recommandé massivement pour autant
quels sont les conséquences sociales
d'une consommation massive de ce contenu
distractif en tout cas l'armée
américaine c'est clairement beaucoup
posé ces questions après tout selon
Wikipédia je cite le film a été
activement soutenu et influencé par le
ministère de la Défense et la marine des
États-Unis d'Amérique afin de présenter
l'armée américaine sous un jour positif
et d'ailleurs à la sortie de certains
cinémas l'armée américaine recrutait qui
plus est toujours selon Wikipédia le
personnage principal du film est inspiré
d'un militaire américain un certain Duke
kenningham et en particulier des
prouesses de ce soldat dans la guerre du
Vietnam une guerre ou plus de bons ont
été largués sur un territoire très
restreint qu'il n'y a eu de bombes
lancées pendant toute la seconde guerre
mondiale il se trouve par ailleurs que
ce même Cunningham est un politicien
corrompu qui a notamment avoué avoir
accepté un chèque de 2,4 millions de
dollars des industries de l'armement et
donc sachant cela est-ce que Top Gun est
vraiment divertissement recommandable à
bien y réfléchir Top Gun semble le
soulever un grave problème un problème
que je vais qualifier de cool washing
autrement dit Top Gun rend cool aux yeux
de millions de spectateurs des
institutions des personnages des valeurs
et des habitudes qui sont en fait très
problématiques pour la sécurité et le
bien-être de l'ensemble de la population
mondiale je parle là bien sûr surtout de
l'engagement dans des forces militaires
sans se préoccuper de la nature de la
légitimité et du bien fondé des conflits
dans lesquels s'efforce armées sont
engagées mais ce n'est pas tout Top Gun
normalisé aussi l'élitisme la
scarification et le masculinisme voire
la consommation de tabac et d'alcool
notamment dans le premier film ou encore
le fait de se comporter en rebelle et de
désobéir mais si je vous parle
aujourd'hui de Top Gun dans cette série
sur alors l'éthique de l'information ce
n'est pas pour critiquer ce film en
particulier le problème du Cool washing
est beaucoup plus générale et ce dont je
vais essayer de vous convaincre c'est
qu'il s'agit même de l'un des plus gros
dangers informationnels pour nous
civilisations en servant bien souvent de
distractions stratégique dont les
entreprises privées et les gouvernements
abusent abondamment pour que les
informations qui les dérangent
deviennent des news c'est à dire des
informations essentiellement réduites
aux silence car beaucoup trop peu
relayer en particulier le plus grand
danger de la spectacularité des IA à mon
sens notamment d'applications comme les
chatbots ou les générateurs d'images
voire des promesses d'application de
l'IA dans des domaines comme la santé le
plus gros problème avec tout ça à mon
sens ça me semble être le Cool washing
que l'enthousiasme pour les IA provoque
en attirant les talents vers le
développement précipité de ces
technologies ce cool washing provoque
non seulement une pénurie de talents en
sécurité des algorithmes et même en
cybersécurité de façon générale mais de
surcroît ils freine la régulation de ces
technologies et l'attention pour leurs
effets secondaires indésirables j'ai
tellement souvent entendu des chercheurs
des ingénieurs et des cadres défendre
l'importance de ne pas freiner le
progrès ou l'innovation parce que tout
ça c'est cool sans que ceci ne prenne
vraiment le temps de bien réfléchir aux
conséquences sociétales de ces
technologies ou même plus simplement au
fait que ces technologies puissent être
réutilisées à des fins malsaines fuites
dans sa vidéo sur la progression
exponentielle du covid en mars 2020 avec
le dicton la seule chose à craindre
c'est l'absence de crainte même
#metalmeta je crains que à cause de la
distraction stratégique et du coup le
washing dans beaucoup de cas comme le
cas du tabac du changement climatique ou
en particulier ici le cas du
développement des IA il y a beaucoup
trop souvent lieu de craindre avant tout
l'absence de crainte bien plus que les
fake news le plus grand danger est ici
celui des Nutte news or malheureusement
les fake news attirent aujourd'hui toute
l'attention et les financements par
exemple niveau académique au niveau
médiatique ou encore au niveau
législatif faisant ainsi du problème des
mute news elle-même une youtubeuse
hashtag méthode
il y a quelques semaines et j'ai eu
l'honneur d'être invité à Flames un
événement académique organisé par meta à
l'Institut Henri poncaré pour ceux qui
n'ont pas suivi meta assez le nouveau
nom de facebook j'y ai parlé des
problèmes de cybersécurité en machine
learning et en particulier de
l'importance des Théo à mathématiques
pour évaluer la vulnérabilité des
algorithmes développés en apprenant des
données d'utilisateur mais le thème
global de la conférence était très
différent il s'agissait davantage de
réunir ceux qui appliquent le machine
learning aux mathématiques et forcée de
constater que les algorithmes modernes
de langage sont capables de prouesse
vraiment spectaculaire souvent même très
largement surhumaine notamment lorsqu'on
les combine à la formalisation
algorithmique des preuves mathématiques
et à des algorithmes de vérification de
preuves et très clairement à cette
conférence big Tak était largement sur
représenté qui s'agisse de Facebook
Google ou autre open eye par opposition
aux académiques qui n'ont généralement
pas accès à suffisamment de
supercalculateurs pour effectuer les
calculs monstrueux nécessaires pour
concevoir des algorithmes sûrs humains
en mathématiques qui plus est à côté des
dizaines le million de dollars
certainement nécessaires pour payer à
facturer électrique des
supercalculateurs qui font des
mathématiques les salaires cumulés des
chercheurs présents à cet événement ce
chiffrait eux aussi certainement dans
les millions de dollars voir les
dizaines de millions de dollars mais
donc pourquoi pourquoi big tech investit
autant dans des domaines qui clairement
ne sont pas les plus utiles à leurs
produits et donc à priori à leurs
revenus pourquoi Facebook pourtant dans
le dur financièrement investi autant
dans le machine learning pour les
mathématiques pourquoi Google a-t-il
racheté type mind et les félicites de
faire des algorithmes pour bien jouer
aux échecs ou Go et aux jeux vidéos ou
pour résoudre des problèmes comme le
repliement de protéines et pourquoi
oppenheye investit autant pour produire
des IA artistes capables de générer des
images spectaculaires ou de converser
avec des millions d'humains de manière
bluffante mais absolument pas lucratives
qu'est-ce qui justifie d'un point de vue
économique le salaire de ses chercheurs
et des machines utilisées pour
développer des algorithmes capables de
mathématiques pures
quelles sont les questions que je
nécessite de poser aux participants de
la conférence et oui j'ai fait ma petite
expérience quand j'étais et bien ce qui
s'est passé c'est que non seulement les
gens n'avaient pas de réponse à la
question mais bien souvent il ne s'était
même jamais posé cette question tous
ceux à qui j'ai parlé était avant tout
beaucoup trop distrait par la
spectacularité des algorithmes qu'ils
avaient développés et bien il me semble
que c'est justement ça l'objectif
économique de cette conférence il
s'agissait de tenir un ton positif sur
l'intelligence artificielle de
s'autoperte soit des formidable
applications potentielles de l'IA et de
ne pas se laisser distraire par les
problèmes géopolitiques que le
développement et le déploiement de ses
algorithmes pose en pratique autrement
dit il s'agissait de normaliser
l'impression que l'IA c'est avant tout
cool et que du coup freiner son progrès
spectaculaire à quelque chose de presque
immoral alors que nombre de leurs
collègues notamment franchis hargen et
sophisang appelle désespérément à ne pas
fermer les yeux sur les applications de
ces intelligences artificielles et en
particulier sur les astrocités
auxquelles les algorithmes de méta ont
largement contribué comme le jeu ici de
des row India le génocide du Tigre et le
chaos informationnel du covid les
émeutes du Capitole les émeutes au
Brésil ou encore la tentative de coup
d'État de l'extrême droite en Allemagne
alors que les étudiants en machine
learning à qui j'ai parlé ont clairement
beaucoup de remords à l'idée même de
candidater ou de travailler pour
Philippe Maurice ou total tous ceux à
qui j'ai parlé étaient heureux d'avoir
candidaté et encore plus d'avoir
décroché des postes à Google ou Facebook
sans donner suffisamment d’attention à
la dangerosité civilisationnelle des
algorithmes développés et déployés par
ces entreprises privées pour beaucoup
trop d'étudiants y compris ceux qui
adhèrent au mouvement altruisme efficace
le machine learning c'est avant tout
super cool y compris tout ce que font
des entreprises privées dangereuses
comme open air de la même façon alors
que invité des chercheurs de FIP Morris
ou de Total dans des institutions
publiques comme l'École polytechnique en
France ou le PFL en Suisse serait vu
comme quelque chose d'absolument
scandaleux qui serait peut-être même
relayé par des médias le fait d'inviter
des chercheurs de Google de Facebook ou
encore d'openha a été complètement
normalisé par les institutions le Cool
washing du machine learning a
terriblement bien marché
il y a aujourd'hui une confusion
dérangeante mais très répandue entre
désinformations et fausses informations
comme si des informer c'était uniquement
produire des fake news cependant les
chercheurs qui ont choisi d'étudier les
producteurs de désinformation constate
au contraire que l'arsenal utilisé par
ses derniers transcende de loin la
simple production de fausses
informations après tout pour désinformer
qui littéralement signifie enlever de
l'information mentir n'est absolument
pas nécessaire un des cas les plus
frappants et les plus documentés et
certains celui de la propagande chinoise
quand la chercheuse de Stanford Jennifer
Pan et ses collègues cherchèrent à la
comprendre ils ont fait la découverte à
leur surprise que cette désinformation
ne produisait que très peu de fausses
informations par ailleurs les énormes
usines de troll payés par des autorités
chinoises ne répondaient en fait pas
souvent aux critiques de ces autorités
au lieu de cela ces trolls étaient
surtout chargés de faire du cheerleading
c'est-à-dire faire l'éloge de l'histoire
du Parti communiste par exemple le parti
leur clairement demandé d'avant tout
s'émerveiller devant tous les symboles
qui lui sont associés avec clairement le
but de détourner l'attention des Chinois
des dangers de l'autoritarisme de la
surveillance de masse et des abus de
trois humains au singes au Tibet ou
encore à Hong Kong on parle pas là d'une
toute petite armée on parle de 20
millions de Chinois payés pour produire
une telle désinformation de la même
manière lorsque de plus en plus de
scientifiques envers à la conclusion que
le sucre est une source majeure
d'obésité de cholestérol et de maladies
cardiovasculaires plutôt que de
directement contredire les études qui
aboutissaient à ses conclusions
l'industrie du sucre a massivement
investi dans la recherche sur les
risques sanitaires du gras au lieu de
nier les dangers du sucre ils ont
cherché ainsi à dévier la tension du
grand public des chercheurs et des
régulateurs ils ont misé sur la
distraction stratégique en fait il y a
même une industrie absolument massive
qui a commercialisé et normalisé cette
stratégie de distraction pour que le
grand public ne prête pas assez danger
vous voyez de quel industrie je veux
parler petit indice cette industrie est
si énorme qu'elle devenue le cœur de
métier de plusieurs des plus grandes
entreprises des technologies je parle là
de l'industrie de la publicité à bien
réfléchir à la publicité qui représente
des centaines de milliards de dollars
d'investissement chaque année cette
publicité ne consiste essentiellement
jamais à mentir ou à nier les risques
elle consiste beaucoup plus à faire
oublier les risques en s'appuyant
notamment abondamment sur le Cool
washing et pour optimiser ce cool
washing beaucoup d'industries
dangereuses ou misées sur des stars
mondiales à l'instar du footballeur
Maradona qui a posé pour Coca-Cola ou de
Beckham Raoul et d'autres joueurs de
football qui ont donné leur visage à
Pepsi en parlant de football justement
on peut mentionner le cas des dictatures
comme le Qatar dont l'économie repose
tant sur le déforme moderne d'esclavage
des migrants et le cas de la FIFA dont
les dirigeants ont clairement été
corrompus par le Qatar c'est même
dirigeant qui suite à aux critiques des
militants des droits humains en amont de
la Coupe du monde monde ont
littéralement appelé à se laisser
distraire par le football et à ne pas
donner d'attention aux souffrances
humaines et d'ailleurs il n'y a pas que
la FIFA à critiquer à ce sujet les plus
grandes superstars de ce sport qui
s'agissent de Mbappé mais si Neymar ou
Cristiano Ronaldo tous son pays par
l'argent sale du pétrole extrait dans
des pays connus pour leurs abus de
droits humains voire pour les meurtres
commandités par les dictateurs au
pouvoir très clairement ces stars comme
d'ailleurs de nombreux influenceurs
servent de cool washing pour donner
avant tout l'impression que ces pays
sont cools et pour réduire autant que
possible au silence les mentions d'abus
de droits humains en parlant de
souffrance humaine justement beaucoup de
membres influent du mouvement altruisme
efficace me semble avoir clairement
abusé de la distraction stratégique
permise par le fait de prétendre vouloir
le bien de l'humanité pour commettre
eux-mêmes des actes illégaux à des
échelles monumentales sans que personne
ne se lave de questions je pense en
particulier à l'escroc
SBF dont fraude financière monumentale
ont clairement été facilités par son
cool washing auprès de l'altruisme
efficace et alors jusque là on a pris
des exemples où le Cool washing est
extrêmement intentionnelle mais à bien
réfléchir la plupart du coûts washing
n'est en fait probablement pas
intentionnelle et c'est en fait là qu'il
est le plus dangereux en effet le
jackpot pour Coca-Cola ce n'est pas tant
qu'en Maradona reçoit de l'argent pour
boire du Coca-Cola devant un milliard de
spectateurs mais le jackpot pour eux
c'est plus encore qu'en des parents
boivent eux-mêmes du Coca-Cola devant
leurs enfants rendant ainsi la
consommation de Coca-Cola cool et
faisant des problèmes de cette
consommation une muteuse auprès des
enfants bref cette liste de couloshin
que je viens de faire n'est absolument
pas exhaustive je vous invite d'ailleurs
à proposer dans les commentaires de
cette vidéo vos propres exemples de
distraction stratégiques dangereuses
entreprises par des entités dangereuses
ou normalisées par l'ensemble de la
population quoi qu'il en soit j'espère
vous avoir convaincu que cette stratégie
te désinformation à une ampleur au moins
aussi alarmante que celle de la
production massif de fausses
informations même si la distraction
stratégique était même loin d'être la
seule autre stratégie utilisée on peut
en effet aussi penser au harcèlement des
critiques à la corruption des preneurs
de décision à l'interdiction de
manifestations notamment dans certains
pays autoritaires à la censure des
opinions politiques divergentes ou
encore à la manipulation des algorithmes
par des faux comptes qui en fait a
peut-être même maintenant une ampleur
encore plus importante
malheureusement la crise
informationnelle est si souvent associée
à la fausse information que les moyens
pour résoudre cette crise comme le
débunking le Fat checking ou le digital
sur F6 actes toutes ces mesures sont en
fait très inadaptées pour combattre
l'inattention aux problèmes importants
pire encore en faisant du problème du
New news une minute news si mesure
peuvent en fait aggraver le problème
attentionnel et donc la crise de
l'information finalement est-ce que le
débunking d'une théorie obscure est
mieux connue n'est-elle pas elle-même
une pollution informationnelle c'est en
fait pour résoudre ce problème de
l'inattention que tournesol a été lancé
en mars 2020 en particulier on s'est
bien rendu compte des lignes attention
alarmantes qu'il y avait au danger du
covid 19 à ce moment là beaucoup plus
que les fausses informations le problème
était que trop peu de gens étaient
exposés à des informations d'intérêts
publics notamment au sujet de la
croissance exponentielle de la pandémie
et sur l'urgence restez chez soi pour
éviter un effondrement des services
hospitaliers pour être précis tout seul
a été lancé un mois et demi après en mai
2020 après la vidéo intitulée La
Bataille de l'information de même
manière si l'industrie du tabac a causé
et cause encore des ravages monumentaux
à hauteur de 8 millions de morts par an
selon l'OMS c'est clairement avant tout
par inattention ou danger que cet objet
représente un manque d'attention dont
beaucoup de fumeurs mais aussi la
société civile et les régulateurs sont
bien trop souvent coupables ou au moins
victimes oui car cette inattention n'est
absolument pas accidentelle en
particulier là encore le Cool washing en
particulier dans les vieux films aura
fortement contribué à l'inattention au
danger de la cigarette de la même
manière si la cause environnementale
abuse de plus en plus d'actions
potentiellement choquantes comme verset
de la soupe sur des œuvres d'art ou des
protestations dans des événements
sportifs majeurs le but de ces
manifestations est avant tout de
combattre l'inattention au changement
climatique dont le grand public et les
politiciens sont trop souvent victimes
ou coupable et si le greenwashing est
souvent jugé très problématique par les
groupes écologistes c'est parce qu'il
risque avant tout d'amplifier
l'inattention à des enjeux qui menacent
les futurs générations et qui provoquent
déjà des souffrances humaines pour des
millions d'humains dans les pays
défavorisés notamment au Pakistan ou à
Madagascar j'en profite pour insister
que très clairement au moins dans ce cas
le problème de l'inattention n'est pas
un problème individuel l'inattention des
uns peut-être criminel vis-à-vis de la
sécurité des autres notamment quand il
s'agit de multimilliardaires qui
profitent étaient revenus du pétrole
dont la consommation massive mettant
danger des vies ailleurs dans le monde
mais j'insiste sur le fait que la cause
environnementale est très loin d'être la
seule à manquer cruellement d'attention
à travers le monde les abus des droits
humains sont omniprésents notamment
dernièrement en Russie en Chine ou
encore en Iran sans parler des cas
catastrophiques de l'Ukraine de Libye du
Yémen du Myanmar ou encore de l'Éthiopie
or bien souvent la tension est critique
pour que les États se mobilise et
viennent en aide aux populations
démunies à l'instar de l'énorme soutien
qui a reçu le peuple ukrainien un
soutien que beaucoup d'autres peuples
n'ont pas reçu dans tous ces cas
l'inattention
une question de vie ou de mort
potentiellement pour des millions
d'individus mais encore une fois la
liste que j'ai donnée des sujets qui
pêchent par inattention et loin d'être
exhaustive je pourrais aussi signaler le
problème de l'inattention au problème de
santé mentale l'invention à la
radicalisation et aux tentatives de coup
d'État il inattention à la cybersécurité
qui aujourd'hui me terrifie plus encore
que les risques de guerre nucléaire mais
pour finir cette liste d'inattention
très dangereuse à mon sens je vais
parler de l'inattention qui me fait le
plus peur à savoir l'inattention aux
algorithmes de recommandation après tout
ces algorithmes sont eux-mêmes le moteur
de l'inattention méthode ce sont ces
algorithmes qui amplifient massivement
certains contenus et qui par voie de
conséquence inéluctable limite
drastiquement la diffusion d'autres
contenus en priorisant davantage la
distraction souvent conçue de manière
stratégique par des campagnes de
désinformation ces algorithmes tuent et
pourtant aujourd'hui trop peu de gens
s'y intéressent en particulier notamment
à cause des efforts monumentaux de
kulwashing de Google meta et d'autres
aujourd'hui aux yeux de l'écrasante
majorité des chercheurs en intelligence
artificielle le machine learning c'est
tellement cool qui serait indésirable de
freiner son progrès et du coup les tours
d'impossibilité sur sécurité du machine
learning qui s'ils étaient pris au
sérieux appellera clairement à ne pas
déployer les solutions existantes aux
yeux de beaucoup de chercheurs c'est
tout à mathématiques sont clairement
chiants et ça ça peut affecter
consciemment ou non la décision
d'acceptation ou de rejet de ces
articles à des conférences scientifiques
et ça affecte plus encore le fait que
ces articles soient cités ou non et donc
le destin académique des chercheurs qui
s'intéressent à la sécurité pire encore
des régulations drastiques et très
contraignantes pour l'innovation sous
souvent jugés indésirables voire
dangereuse par ces scientifiques bref
pour toutes ces raisons de nos jours il
me semble plus problématique de
s’enthousiasmer devant chaque GPT sans
donner d'attention majores énormes
manque de sécurité de ce produit que
d'écrire un article sueur les 10
avantages du sucre pour la santé et j'ai
été assez surpris de voir que ce genre
d'articles existe
l'inattention à la distraction
stratégique conduit malheureusement
beaucoup à penser que la solution en
contre la désinformation repose sur la
modération contre la fausse information
mais très clairement si on considère que
l'inattention à la crise
environnementale aux problèmes de santé
mentale et à l'amplification de la haine
entre autres est un aspect majeur de la
crise informationnelle alors bien modéré
est très clairement très largement
insuffisant pour vraiment résoudre la
crise d'informationnelle dès lors la
question qu'il convient de se poser
c'est davantage à quelles informations
les 8 milliards d'humains devraient être
exposés de manière quotidienne quelles
sont les distractions qui ne mettent pas
de vie en danger et quels sont les
informations auxquelles nous devons
absolument prêter attention en
particulier si vous étiez l'algorithme
de recommandation de YouTube quelle
vidéo afficheriez-vous sur les
téléphones des milliards d'utilisateurs
lorsque ceux-ci clique sur l'application
de YouTube ou plus concrètement encore
que voudriez vous mettre dans le
rectangle jaune affiché dans la page
d'accueil de youtube Des indicateur de
l'extinction navigateur de tournesol
disponible sur Firefox et Chrome faut-il
que les vidéos sur le changement
climatique intègre plus souvent sur
rectangle jaune vous faut-il davantage
de contenu sur les protestations en
Chine et en Iran quand est-il de la
santé mentale ou encore des algorithmes
de recommandation quelles sont les
sujets qui doivent être intégrés au
rectangle jaune de recommandations de
tournesol et bien c'est parce que nous
pensons qu'il faut répondre
collaborativement à ces questions que
nous avons développé la plateforme
tournesol il y a maintenant deux ans et
demi désormais la plateforme est
parfaitement fonctionnelle et ce dont on
a désormais le plus besoin pour avancer
dans notre combat contre la distraction
stratégique des multinationales et des
dictatures plus globalement contre
l'inattention aux problèmes les plus
importants de nos sociétés modernes ce
dont on a le plus besoin c'est que vous
nous étiez à répondre à ces questions
vous pouvez tous nous aider à déterminer
quelle vidéo doivent intégrer le
rectangle jaune de tournesol pour nous
aider tout ce que vous avez à faire
c'est créer compte sur tournesol vous
connectez à votre compte et nous dire
ensuite entre deux vidéos que vous avez
vues par exemple récemment laquelle de
ces deux vidéos devrait plus souvent
intégrer le rectangle jaune de tournesol
et notez que pour répondre à ces
questions il est clairement critique de
comparer toutes sortes de vidéos y
compris des vidéos qui parlent de sujets
très différents en fait c'est
précisément ainsi que vous nous aiderez
à déterminer collaborativement quel
contenu sont des news qui souffrent
d’inattention et devra ainsi être
davantage discuté j'espère que je peux
compter sur vous pour nous aider à
combattre l'inattention aux enjeux
majeurs du présent et du futur dont les
distractions stratégiques des campagnes
de désinformation sont si souvent
responsables